au sri lanka aujourd'hui ne se bat plus
r
[Applaudissements]
oh
chaque samedi ils sont des milliers à se
bousculer dans un intercity
[Musique]
cette ligne a rouvert en octobre 2004
enfin 5
elle est aujourd'hui le simple deux
villes
et même en dehors entend chanter dans
les deux langues
cinghalais
ces jeunes étudiants tamouls rentrée
pour les congés de fin d'année à
chartres à vivre leur part
le trajet l'eau
plus de huit heures ont traversé tous
depuis
autant que cela prenait pendant la
guerre
disons qu'on imagine que dans la rue et
sur la boutique ou de barrages ou la
police beaucoup trop d'alcool
et maintenant cerné par les legs
nous pénétrons sur cette mythique
péninsule un doigt de terre qui sent
mieux et pour le absents
m
jaffna devait devenir la capitale du
pays que les tigres et séparatistes
tamouls
les deux crimes
vu d'en haut ce n'est pourtant qu'une
forêt de laquelle dépasse quelques
églises catholiques et des torts blog
les deux religions de milan
et sous les arbres captent à respirer
après des décennies de guerres ses
habitants boeck se déplacer librement
les jeunes sortir en plein air et c'est
lui
un air de liberté même si les militaires
ne sont jamais très loin
dans la réalité en effet la ville est
toujours sous la chape de plomb de la
colombe on relit pleut que tout le
retour des vérités c'est pas la crise
les reportages des rites est
impossible d'obtenir un visa
journalistes alors nous sommes
contraints de jouer les touristes
notre premier rendez vous a lieu la nuit
nous voulons éviter d'être suis car
l'homme qui nous attend est surveillé
depuis plusieurs années par les
renseignements sri lankais
prémat nantes
m de uthayan le premier quotidien
tamouls du pays
regardez ça tous les fils sont
totalement brûlés mieux si on ne peut
plus rien utiliser plus du tout
il y a un an et demi trois hommes armés
incendies les bureaux du journal pour
prennent pas de doute c'est la signature
des paramilitaires ces miliciens
employait par des membres du
gouvernement pour éliminer les
défenseurs de la cause tamoule
uthayan dénonce les discriminations dont
ils sont victimes
et ce n'est pas du goût du gouvernement
central
ils veulent nous réduire au silence
aujourd'hui nous sommes forcés de nous
censurer même nous n'avons pas la
liberté d'écrire tous 15 millions nous
réfléchissons à deux fois avant d'écrire
quelque chose et même plus que deux fois
voilà notre situation
et mains sont liées
malgré cette répression uthayan kir
chaque jour à plus de 50000 exemplaires
pendant la guerre mais ces dernières
années aussi
il a subi des dizaines d'attaqués
[Musique]
sur le mur d'une des salles du journal
c'est à les portraits de tous les
journalistes victimes
si vous voyez cette route
ce sont les impacts des balles
cela s'est produit en 2006
c'était la veille de la journée de la
liberté de la presse
cet homme armé se rencontrer dans nos
bureaux
et jusqu'à aujourd'hui nous gardons ces
preuves de l'attak pour ne jamais
oublier parce que c'était une attaque
contre la liberté de la presse
comme dans les bureaux de uthayan à
jaffna les cicatrices de la guerre
civile sont encore visibles la ville a
été presque entièrement détruite dans
les années 80
quasi totalité les habitants de la
région sont à moules aujourd'hui ils se
disent discriminés par la majorité
bouddhiste cinghalaise qui a gagné la
guerre et dirige le pays à proximité
déjà fta prennent nous emmène voir ses
vingt-cinq mille tamouls qui près de six
ans après la fin des combats vivent
toujours
pendant la guerre ils ont fui les
bombardements aujourd'hui l'armée leur
interdit de revenir sur la terre des
terres qu'elle a annexée pour y
construire des bases militaires mais
aussi des usines ou encore des hôtels
nous avons des champs cultivés nous
avons la maison vivre
ici il n'y a rien pour nous
les militaires gardent à l'oeil ces
réfugiés et viendrait régulièrement les
questionner
vous expliquer nos conditions si on
parle
de vivre ici et de ne pas trop parler
tous ici ont peur des représailles
nous ne resterons pas longtemps la
police et l'armée ne sont jamais très
loin les autorités ne souhaite pas
montrer les conditions de vie dans ces
camps sans eau potable ni électricité
et puis il y a les mines six ans après
la guerre la péninsule de jaffna on est
toujours parsemée des mines posées par
les tigres tamouls et l'armée sri
lankaise il y en aurait eu plus d'un
million dans la région
aujourd'hui encore les ong nettoie les
champs mais il ya toujours des victimes
krishna a perdu sa jambe il ya un an en
marchant sur l'une d'entre elles
après avoir perdu ma jambe c'est devenu
très difficile pour moi de travailler
dans les champs je vais beaucoup
cultivent et récoltent et comme je le
faisais avant
notre vie était déjà très compliquée
mais maintenant qu'il a perdu sa jambe
c'est pire je m'inquiète vraiment
beaucoup pour son futur est le nôtre
après tout c'est le chef de famille
malgré ces difficultés krishna tente de
mener une vie normale
comme beaucoup à jaffna
cette femme en rose on a peut-être plus
l'air mais pendant la guerre elle était
membre des féroces qui doit tamouls ces
guérilleros craint pour leurs attentats
suicide et le recrutement d'enfants
soldats à la fin du conflit elle a passé
plus d'un an dans un camp de détention
alors il ya beaucoup d'embouteillages
aujourd'hui ça simatic travail dans un
petit hôpital effet les visites à
domicile
elle a pris ses médicaments
elle jure qu'elle appartenait au corps
médical des petits gros tamouls des
compétences acquises pendant la guerre
qui lui aurait servi à se reconvertir
je suis vieille
caisse que l'âge grand mère ne vous
inquiétez pas ne pensais pas trop à tout
cela
le travail est le même qu'avant
des gens malades
avant
aujourd'hui je travaille quand de
l'argent que je gagne
peu de gens acceptent d'embaucher des
anciens tigres tamouls dont beaucoup
sont des femmes
l'hôpital où travaille sa sima qui est
une exception 90% de ses collègues
infirmières sont des ex guérillera
elle ne parle pas aux patients de leur
passé la plupart disent même tout faire
pour l'oublier pourtant chaque jour la
simple vue des médicaments réveille les
souvenirs de la guerre
[Musique]
à
la fin de la guerre il y avait tellement
de combattants blessés civils des
enfants des personnes
malades
aujourd'hui je suis heureuse que vous
avez tous ces médicaments conçoivent et
des
jardins se soigne et reprenant comme
c'est le cas du port de pêche avant le
conflit c'était une activité vitale la
région de jaffna fournissait alors
offrir en quatre un quart de ses besoins
en boisson
prem le journaliste tamoul voeu de faire
visiter le marché le plus important de
la prénationale ce matin il ya du monde
mais surtout des petits pois sur la
sarre die dans la romance et les crabes
60 roupies le poisson 70
depuis la fin des combats le
gouvernement a tenté de soutenir
l'activité élargissant les autres de
pêche autorisés mais pour les pêcheurs
côtiers galles la peña fan et la russie
[Musique]
vous êtes
r on voulait empêcher que dans une ue
doit hélas aujourd'hui nous pouvons
aller plus loin mais dans l'adaptation
des ne se sont pas
il ya des gros bateaux de longue date
qui viennent pêcher sur deux ils sont
mieux et au final nos revenus ont
diminué
g can a tout de même de la chance il
possède un bateau beaucoup de non pas
dans le nord le taux de chômage serait
deux fois supérieur à celui du reste du
pays
pourtant les signes de la reconstruction
commencent à apparaître complexe
immobilier groupe 9
jaffna affiche même une croissance
insolente de plus de 20% par
un mur orné de symboles car green square
ce centre commercial a ouvert il ya un
an
ça y est il y à 24 ans elle est vendeuse
avec candeur elle admet que si elle
n'avait pas trouvé ce travail ses
parents l'auraient sans doute déjà marié
ici tu peux mais sur une dizaine de
personnes une salle vient vraiment faire
des achats les autres viennent
simplement il passait du temps il y as
l'air conditionné et beaucoup de choses
à voir et puis c'est un lieu où garçons
et filles peuvent se retrouver sans que
leurs parents sont au courant
même les élèves viennent ici c'est chez
les cheminots
à l'instar de ce supermarché les modes
de vie à jaffna mais aussi les habits
au niveau des consommateurs se mettent à
ressembler à ceux du monde
pourtant les tamouls sont aussi attachés
à leur lit pendant la guerre ce prêtre
catholique a créé un centre culturel où
les jeunes de jaffna apprenait les arts
traditionnels kaboul aujourd'hui les
élèves sont moins nombreux et toujours
aussi jeune il faut donc régulièrement
au début tu vas trouvé ça difficile mais
ne te décourage pas
le bharata natyam et qui dans ce
complexe indiqué dans les cultures
antiques pour apaiser les dieux faut des
années pour maîtriser les mouvements
beaucoup de tamouls chrétiens ou hindous
redoute aujourd'hui que le gouvernement
de colombo contre les parigots disent tu
lis par effacer les particularismes
développement économique g roupe en
installent amènent les murs nous avons
le train maintenant pour aller au
supermarché
vraiment c'est de perdre en gc
cette peur a permis à l'opposition de
créé la surprise en remportant début
janvier avec l'appui des partis kaboul
les élections nationales
le nouveau premier ministre a promis de
mettre fin aux discriminations contre
les tamouls du gouvernement pressé
verte à l'aspect final
une ville comme les dans un pays qui a
peur
aurait réussi